hey guys it's Justine and I've been
making YouTube videos since about 2006
and until about a year ago I edited and
shot almost all of those myself
yes very time consuming most recently I
started working with Tyler
he helps shoot and edit videos so now I
wanna walk you guys through a workflow
that we've been using to work remotely
the three main tools we use our final
cut for editing frame i/o for file
storage and transfer and post lab for
sharing final cut libraries in the cloud
romão plays a huge part in how we
transfer all of our footage each of our
projects has a unique folder that we
upload everything to it we're going to
need for the video and using their
desktop transfer app we can easily and
really quickly download multiple folders
full of all of the files at once the
subfolder structure will all stay intact
and you even have the option of
downloading the original or two
different proxy size versions of the
files it's such a great platform when
you're collaborating with multiple
people and it's been so key for us to
stay organized when we're all working in
different places until a few weeks ago
when we discovered post-lab we thought
we had this really great workflow
editing system set up we would send each
other the xml's I would import then
post-lab was brought into our lives and
it has absolutely changed everything
both lab is an app that makes
collaborating with multiple editors
remotely super simple and efficient it
will save and sync your libraries so
anyone can work on it from anywhere I
love the time machine history showing
who was working on what so there's no
guessing what changes were made by
someone else everything is tracked and
saved this works on Mac OS with Final
Cut and even premiere I've also been
working with my sister Jenna we just
recently started a podcast and she also
has her own YouTube channel I taught
Jenna to edit maybe like eight or nine
years ago so sometimes from time to time
she'll have an editing question but now
in post lab I can even open up her
library I can even make the change for
her tell her what I did and then she can
use that as an excuse to ask me
basically edit her video for her I see
what she's doing
Sneaky's free Maya was also incredible
if
you have somebody else editing a video
it allows you to make timecode comments
you can do time ranges and you can even
make a visual comments you can tell the
person editing exactly where you want
the change Frank Mayo is also amazing
because it has a final cut workflow
extension so when I make my notes in
frame IO either on my iphone my iPad or
on a computer those will show up to
Tyler and then he can import those into
Final Cut and it'll overlay exactly
where the changes are this gives you a
really nice visual representation in the
timeline of where the changes have to be
made I also love this link playhead
feature this will let you click the
comments in the frame i/o work flow
extension and it will automatically snap
to that timecode on the final cut
timeline you can then easily export it
out and upload it directly to the frame
io shared folder for review let's head
over to Tyler's house so he can show you
guys how we get the project started
[Music]
so what I'm doing right now is starting
this project inside post labs so here is
the iJustine post lab team inside here
we have some productions and some
folders so what I'm going to do is
create a new production so you come down
here to this plus button and click
production and then it'll give you an
option to name the production I'm going
to call this iPhone se test so I'm gonna
hit create but there's nothing in here
yet
so we're gonna make a Final Cut Pro
library by clicking here and selecting
new library and from here we can open
the project and start editing so I'm
going to click start editing right here
and it just automatically opens up Final
Cut and from here you can just import
footage and music and everything else
like you normally would from your media
storage location and now I'm just gonna
get started editing this project oh just
oh my goodness it looks like jenna is
actually working right now let me scream
share this just to prove it Co the thing
right here this library is locked by
jenna is Eric which means she's working
on the podcast
hi my name is Jenna I have been making
YouTube videos for 10 years but as of
recently I am now going to be a co-host
of a podcast
first episode I am on editing duty and I
am taking it very very very seriously
because well it's our first episode so
post-lab has been incredible for many
reasons now years ago probably ten years
ago my sister Justine taught me how to
edit I'm pretty good but I'm not as good
as her so I always am asking her
questions and I'm like sending her files
only can you just edit this and send it
back this has been great because I've
actually secretly been like having her
and it for me
I don't like color grading her being the
nice person that she is she'll go ahead
help me and then I can just copy and
paste her color attributes to the rest
of my timeline and I didn't have to do
anything
[Music]
this is really exciting because you can
go in and you can kind of see all of the
changes that happened inside of this
folder so right here I started the
library I started working on it I think
the audio added color I started a new
podcast project I started some of the
edits and now today as we speak and I
film this Jenna is starting to work on
the final edit for the full-length
podcast episode and then I love in here
there's tasks so I can give out
different tasks to people oh she has
assigned me some tasks alright so I'm
going to respond back to here and let
her know that I'm working on it
Justine has already managed to set up
all the multi cams and sync all the
audio because she it's also not my
favorite thing so now I'm gonna go ahead
and make sure that the rest of the
podcast looks good I wonder if she's
gonna like right out of this sound
effect oh did you guys through that so
now that Jen was working on the podcast
I'm gonna check in with Tyler and see
where he's at so it's the next day and
I've got a pretty good edit on this
video done and now I'm going to upload
that progress to post lab and because
Justine and I have all the same footage
and content on matching hard drives
she'll be able to open up that project
and look at it no problem here it says
upload your work and I'm going to
describe what I have changed and it's
really funny if you just try to say like
edited and hit upload it gives you an
error you can do better than that
good job post lab okay edit complete
that's good and then we just click
upload and what it does here is it
closes the library in Final Cut Pro and
logs it in post lab and here it is as a
timeline of all the changes that have
happened and logs at all in this nice
little list and then when Justine opens
this on her computer she can click start
editing or she can open a copy to take a
look at what I've done but I have a
feeling Justine might have some notes so
what I'm actually gonna do is open this
back up and I'm going to upload this to
frame i/o so that she can make notes if
she has any I'm sure the Edit is perfect
because I'm
but just in case she has any notes I'm
going to upload this differently
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's it now it's gonna export the
video and automatically upload it to
frame IO and I can go eat some raisin
bran and go along so it's exciting Tyler
just said that he is sending me a frame
a link of a proof of the video so the
first round is done so I made all my
changes and notes in frame IO and now
I'm going to open up post lab for the
first time to actually see what the
library is that Tyler is working on so I
can go into our project here and I can
download the whole project library to my
computer so once this downloads I can
see everything that Tyler's been working
on since he first started the library
I'm gonna mark this project as in
progress
and since Tyler's not working on it now
I can go directly into the library and
start editing when I first open the
project up I need to relink although the
files it's only has to be done the first
time you open the library post-lab will
maintain the linked footage for each
user even if they have the files in
different places on their drives this
couldn't be done before when working
remotely without closed lab we were
basically working on the same Final Cut
library just in different places so I've
got some notes back from Justine and I'm
going to go in and make some changes and
what I can do is use the frame i/o
workflow extension it's very cool
so it's this button right up here in the
top and you click that and it opens up
this window inside Final Cut where you
can review videos and notes right inside
the filter bro so I've rearranged my
windows here a little bit and I've got
the frame i/o extension on the left and
Final Cut Pro on the right and here's
why the frame i/o extension is really
cool I can come here to this little
button that says link play heads and
when I click that it's going to link all
of these comments to my project timeline
so when I click on one of these comments
you'll see that my project playhead
skipped exactly to that point in the
video and when I click on another
comment make title read at iJustine boom
the playhead skips back to that point in
the timeline another option here
is instead of using the link play heads
feature I can actually import all of
these comments as sort of like an
adjustment layer on top of my project
and Final Cut and all I have to do is
click import this window pops up this is
import comments and then I'm just gonna
click and drag this over to Final Cut it
is overlaid into my timeline all the
notes I can stay within my timeline and
scroll through here and make all the
changes so if I scroll to the first note
here you can see it here in the window
make title read I just think I already
did that I know I messed that up and so
let's go to the next note and the note
reads audio accidentally muted here yes
it was that is my bad so that's it I can
just go through this whole timeline make
all these changes and then upload back
to post lab it's so incredibly
convenient because I can take exactly
what he was working on and just pick up
right where he left off between final
cut frame IO and post lab we have
developed a really incredible workflow
for editing remotely if you guys have
any questions at all feel free to leave
them in the comments and I will put a
link in the description so you guys can
check out frame IO and post lab and I
hope that this video has helped you guys
get a sense of what is possible when you
are working remotely this has completely
changed the way that we work and I
cannot wait to get back to editing I
love to edit and this has made it so
much more fun
[Music]